[Music]
hide
um
um
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a
beta what are we talking about
there are males most men today
[Music]
that's a lot
everything abortion
act just like a woman a better man
does it because he is a logical thinking
and then controlled by the darkness of
david
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
[Music]
bizarre questions
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
big massive dumpsters
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
[Music]
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
dumps dumps
what is going on
here it's just beyond parody massive
dumps cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on please
proceed governor
it's just beyond parody i mean massive
dumps cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
big
big massive
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we have a
packed packed stream today um i will
later be joined by
stephen kenneth destiny benell ii
we are going to try to clear the air i
guess for lack of a better term
um
we are also going to be speaking to ian
vosh a little bit later i actually don't
remember
what we're talking about we've been
trying to set up a stream for a little
while
and
what is the topic i actually don't
remember but we'll be speaking to ian
vosh a little bit later so it's going to
be a
it's just a it's stuffed the stream is
stuffed full of stuff
and it's great to have everybody here
hope everybody's thanksgiving was good
yesterday to the extent that you
celebrated i think for lack of a better
term
and um
that's uh that's what's happening so on
the agenda
i am going to be talking about the stock
market dip today nearly four percent
decline in one day the russell 2000
index on a shortened trading day related
to the new covet variant a lot of people
panicking
i think
it's it's called a variant of concern
not a variant of panic
and we'll talk about why we should be
concerned but not yet panicked um we're
also going to be looking at the new
lauren bobo bobert video
uh very xenophobic aspects to that
i
also had people ask me to recommend
espresso machines i might have been a
joke but i'm going to do it
and i'm also i've been asked am i ready
to
totally denounce tesla
so we're going to talk a little bit
about electric cars we'll have some of
your voicemails we will have um super
chats
and we will speak to stephen kenneth
destiny
bennell
ii and also ian vosh a little bit later
so all of that is happening it's a uh
is it freaky friday i don't know it's
not a term i use
but it is friday it is friday will i
talk about crypto today probably not um
i don't really have anything else to say
about crypto today
unless people want me to say something
specific about it i don't know
um okay let me thank people uh it is yes
we are unbanned from twitch i don't know
why we just are we were banned for 30
days but then after 11 they let us back
on
um i want to say thank you to savvy
lemons duck company
heldardo
beef stews dloms and robot mugabe
putting us at six
we do have a code for today the code is
obama
you can see it right over my head and it
saves you 68
at
joinpackman.com
super chat's the only one so far is from
jessica i know it's not even on the
screen yet uh the question is who is the
guy that created and is shown in your
opening
big massive dumps remix that is office
akimov i i mislabeled him as officer
akimov
some period of time ago but it is
actually office akimov he also did the
uh i don't even know if i have it here
oh he did this remix as well moment of
the sexual experience will ask the young
lady who's your daddy this should be
remixed if officer akimov is watching
this could and it was not officer akima
of it's i think officer akimov does
sound better to be totally frank with
you guys but he goes by office akimov
all right so let's just let's just get
right into it because um
see this is an annoying somebody said no
one cares who it is
that's literally wrong someone just
asked who it is so by definition someone
cares who it is
really weird
uh
i guess it's cool to say no one cares
but all right very good
um
let's continue all right so
massive stock market decline today worst
day of 2021 s p 500 down 2.27 percent
dow
down 2.53
nasdaq or nasdag as the former president
used to call it down 2.23 percent and
the widest index of these four the
russell 2000
down a brutal
3.67 percent
why well
because of the new covet variant
us announces travel restrictions over
new coveted variant
who designates new coronavirus variant
of concern naming it omicron
okay
the world health organization will label
the new variant as a variant of concern
there was a meeting a technical working
group etc etc it's a variant of concern
um statement released by the who the new
strain will be given the name omicron
based on the evidence presented
indicative of a detrimental change in
covet epidemiology
the tag v has advised who that this
variant should be designated voc and the
who has designated it b11529
as omicron
variant first discovered
by south african health authorities so
here's the thing there was so much
um i don't want to call it
misinformation or disinformation in the
chat before we started there were just a
lot of assertions being made for which
we don't yet have evidence so for
example people in the chat before we
started were saying the vaccines don't
work
or it's deadlier
or
whatever
we don't know that yet
we don't know that yet now for people
saying oh
when will the variance stop the variants
never stop the evolution of the virus
and the mutation continues the question
is does it do any of the things some
people are saying it does and we're
going to look at what we know so far now
is it possible
that this new variant
is far more deadly it's possible
is it possible that this new variant
evades the vaccines it's possible
do we know that yet no we don't
no we don't
uh so let's get into some of this data
um andy slavitt
covet update see this we we have to be
more sober about this covet update a new
variant in southern africa has emerged
and is grabbing local concern
what do we know and should we be worried
good
in situations like this
it's useful to separate into what is
known with good certainty what is
unknown and what is being speculated
then i will address the what if question
okay we're gonna go through it piece by
piece
known
b11529 we now know of as omicron
originated in south africa and botswana
and cases have been recorded among
travelers in belgium hong kong and
israel
what we know so far doesn't paint a full
picture
the variant has a lot of mutations over
50. the ace2 receptor which allows the
virus to bind to our cells has over 10
mutations
there is a lot more that we don't know
while there are still limited number of
cases that mutation profile has
scientists concerned that possibly
neither prior immunity nor vaccine will
be effective or as effective at
preventing spread of infection so
remember
this is what
you have to look at the language
scientists are concerned
possibly
not effective or not as effective
right so if everybody's saying vaccines
don't work it's too early to say that
some of the characteristics of the
variant are reminiscent of beta and
lambda two variants that became
concerning but ultimately haven't been
able to compete with delta
there was panic around those
it will take two weeks or so to test in
a lab two weeks
whether the mrna vaccines are effective
and if so how effective they are we do
not know it yet when people say hey two
people in south africa who got this
were vaccinated that is not a
scientifically and empirically robust
data point
it will take two weeks to test in a lab
whether the vaccines are effective
in the meantime there will be
speculation and that's what we're seeing
it is reported many of the cases were
among younger people in south africa who
are largely unvaccinated does it mean
something maybe
south africa has one of the most
sophisticated detection systems many
scientists have pointed the lower
vaccination levels and an abundance of
immunocompromised people is a breeding
ground for new variants this also leads
to speculation that there is more spread
than discovered currency stock bond and
oil traders began the day near panic
airline stocks down netflix up
people who get paid to speculate will
speculate for the rest of us there's no
sport in it
read what is actually being said here
the unanswered questions are important
ones even if a variant creates more
difficulty for the immune system its
rate of spread is important if it
doesn't outcompete delta it will likely
be more limited in his reach as long as
delta continues to spread we've all
gotten nervous enough it's worth
answering the question but what if it
does evade prior immunity and outcompete
delta it's foolhardy to predict the
future but smart to prepare and we've
been preparing the mrna vaccines are
built on a platform which allow for very
rapid development of new vaccines if
that should happen
both pfizer and moderna estimate 100
days to do a vaccine for a new variant
could take longer
manufacturing approval and distribution
take time but we're getting more
efficient if we start in early december
new vaccines would be available by the
summer and much of the world this
explains europe already dealing with
waves and worries over variants decided
to shut down travel from south africa
until more is learned
banning travel hasn't seemed to be
anything close to a panacea right it's
already in israel hong kong belgium at
minimum
it punishes countries and their
economies and make uh who make and
report discoveries
um we the g20 couldn't vaccinate africa
fast enough despite abundant vaccines
and so now we will increase the cost to
them of our
failure uh let me see if there's
anything else relevant here this is the
gist of it okay but the panic is
happening
dow tumbles 900 points for worst day of
year on fears of new covet variant
so
am i doing anything as far as stocks go
if anybody who knows me knows i'm not
i'm just going to keep buying more
i'm uh in it for the long haul i will
just continue to buy
not making any moves as far as that goes
uh crypto crypto dropped today eight
percent
uh not doing anything just gonna just
gonna keep going holding the line
um
what else did i have on this
oh okay
uh john byrne murdoch
from the financial times
five quick tweets on the new variant
caveat first data here is very
preliminary
based on data we have this variant is
out competing others faster than beta
and delta did that's the assertion
that's being made
um this is how quickly
this
variant spread
in south africa
south africa has very particular
situation low level of young people
being vaccinated
uh in addition to
um
significant sequencing and testing
i don't know that we can
say too much from that yet and remember
this is the this is the share of cases
that are this variant this is not
absolute cases very important to
understand
two
this is coinciding with a wider rise in
cases in south africa
so here's what we're talking about so
far okay
so
might it be time to panic maybe
do we know that no we don't know that
we don't know that
um
the other reason for concern is that the
mutations are
known
to be associated
with greater transmissibility and immune
evasion we do not know that yet
and then here are the caveats this
variant wasn't known about last week
it's early
case rates were very low when it emerged
urgent search for more data means some
growth could be due to targeted testing
and sequencing there is cause for
concern it is a variant of concern not a
variant of panic
um update here on
the merck pill for people waiting for
that
it does not appear to be 50 effective at
reducing severe infection but rather 30
so when we had that early data on the
pill the coveted pill and we said well
50 is great but that's early it looks
like it's more like 30.
so that is a tool that
will be available but it is not going to
be as great of a tool
um and what else did i have on that i
think that's really it
um again the point here is there is a
lot that we just don't know yet
um
oh i've also been asked about this new
video from dr john campbell not a
medical doctor if we're going to say
that about everybody we've got us we've
got to actually be clear dr john
campbell not a medical doctor
has a new video about ivermectin
and many of you have written to me and
you said
something smells funky about that video
let me see if i can even find it
ivermectin in japan
this is the video
okay
and uh it's called ivermectin in japan
has nearly a million views and many of
you wrote to me and said david you know
you've really got to look closely at
this video it seems as though
not all is honest about this video
and here's the thing
i'm looking at
doing a point by point on this video
but if i do what i want to make sure i
do it right
and there's a lot here but
as some examples
um let me pull up my let me let me even
pull up my notes
because there's a lot here in fact i
don't even know that i should do this
yet i should probably be better prepared
but um
you know
in in this video
dr john campbell not a medical doctor
appears to lay out
the case that it may well be ivermectin
that's responsible for the low cases in
japan
when there's so many different things
that were going on at exactly this time
number one
massive amounts of testing because of
the olympics
um
an extremely strict lockdown and on and
on and on
and
he's sort of low-key suggesting it may
be ivor mektin it may be iver mektin
that is responsible for this i don't
believe we know that at all to be the
case
and the concern of course is
there are a lot of people
who um
want ivermectin to be the solution
and i would love ivermectin to be the
solution i would love it you know i have
absolutely no ideological attachment for
or against any particular medicine
uh it would be great if ivermectin were
the solution this video did not convince
me
and uh
in any case i don't know it's some we we
may look at that more closely we may not
i'm just not sure at this point but it's
we're considering it okay
let me say thank you to
nobody oh my god i have nobody to thank
okay let me look at a few super chats
and then we're going to move on to a few
other
things here uh remember when trump
tweeted cop fee in 2017 and then kovit
was discovered two years later i'm not
saying trump is behind covet i'm just
asking questions here okay
it's true what they say women are from
omicron per se seven men are from
omicron per se nine right
omicron per se eight
given variants will emerge is it safer
for the u.s to spend more to try to
change the minds of non-vaccinated or
send vaccines to poor countries we have
enough vaccines to do both we have
enough vaccines and money to do both
la pavoni euro piccola and rancilio
rocky great combo for under a thousand
dollars usd wow
i am no one i care
new variant was detected in low vaccine
areas
i watched 12 angry men after the written
house trial really makes you think about
the backgrounds of jurors deciding
someone's fate very much so
do you play among us it's a very sussy
game i have never played it
i've never played it however i was
invited by the great anna rudolph to
participate in
some kind of
uh squid game related thing at some
point i said i would love to do it but i
just uh we got to find a time to do it i
want to say thanks to napa skip dog for
the twitch prime subscription you're
number seven today also also thanks to
kismar for donating five subs today and
you can use the coupon code obama
to get a heavily discounted membership
on my website
the website is joinedpakman.com and i
would love for you to sign up i will
thank you and it will be
um an incredible thing all right let's
get into some other things now i know
there are some people in the audience
who don't care about these upcoming
things but i've been asked to cover them
so i'm going to cover them anyway the
first one is david can you recommend
espresso machines i am i am only an a
very casual espresso enthusiast so i am
not claiming
i'm not claiming to be giving anything
other than my mildly informed opinion
now if you're looking for a two or two
hundred dollar espresso machine i don't
know
what to recommend uh i would maybe check
out like james hoffman i think his name
is or something something like that uh
he has a great coffee related channel um
i can only talk to you about machines
i'm familiar with now if you were
looking for something if you're let me
put it this way
if you're
ready
to move beyond entry level
and you want something you don't have to
think too much about
that'll last you a long time with a
built-in grinder
there is no better recommendation than
the breville barista express now here it
says that it's a 700 machine that may be
the case now
i've had one for uh
six years now
and when i got it it was 5.79
i am glad to be talked out of this
but i can't think of at this price point
a better machine
as long as you take care of it okay and
that means
you've got to do the descaling
you've got to do the back flushing
you've got to do all those different
things now there are people in the chat
who will say built-in grinder is a
disaster
um
i i understand i understand
um this is a good enough grinder
and
you get your money back i mean think
about this
i've had one of these for
six years
if you make let me see if i can do some
math on this
six years let's assume i'm making
let's call it eight drinks a week
times i mean let's take some time away
let's let's assume it's only even
44 weeks a year
times six years that's over 2 000 drinks
your average cappuccino call it 450 at a
nice cafe you know that's nearly 10
grand
and you know the cost of milk and beans
when you're using a system like this is
very very minor
so you know if you use it it's
absolutely absolutely worth it um so
this would be my recommendation if
you're like okay i'm ready to go beyond
like a 200 thing
all right fair now if you're looking to
go to the next
level
i've looked at a lot of different
machines
and this is now for now now remember
yeah eight drinks a week isn't a lot
there's people who are who are having
you know 14 21 28 right you know it's
crazy um anyway if you're looking to go
to the next level and i'm not even gonna
get into like three four five thousand
dollar machines but just like the next
level i'm partial
to the rocket apartamento
i think it's a it's a delightful machine
now here you no longer have a built-in
um you no longer have a built-in grinder
you're talking about a lot more stuff i
think this thing is like 1800 bucks but
in looking at a lot of different reviews
i think that this is a really really
great machine um i do think you're
supposed to have that look on your face
when you use it but that is sort of up
to you guys
but um yeah this this would be my next
thing like if i was in the fifteen
hundred dollar to two thousand dollar
level this is this is what i would be
looking at right here
and of course none of these are like
fully automatic or anything like that if
you're looking for that you gotta i
don't know anything about that you gotta
look at a different category all right
so we are done with the espresso stuff
now next topic that people ask me to
address
am i ready to say it's time to abandon
tesla
is it time to abandon tesla now many of
you know i've been a shareholder since
2015.
i did panic sell half
when elon musk said really crazy things
on the joe rogan program and i believe
it was 2018 2017 something like that
um and i sold half and then it's it's
just gone up up up and many of you know
that i also drive one of these vehicles
um
here's my thought at this point on tesla
and i am making no analysis of the stock
at all this is an analysis of the
product
i said from the very beginning
uh tesla's advantage is not that they
make the best cars in terms of build
quality and feel
tesla's advantage is a first mover
advantage they were the first to have
cars electric cars with this range
okay
however
there are other companies out there
that know how to make cars much better
than tesla making hard cars is tough
and
my belief years ago was at a certain
point
these other companies are going to catch
up to tesla
and the quality
is better
what cars am i talking about really when
you're talking about electric sedans
that compete with the model s
i'm talking about three different
vehicles all
which
i believe
are higher quality
than tesla
the three cars are
the audi e-tron gt
okay if you look at the quality of this
vehicle
the wind noise
the
um
the everything the doors the buttons
everything
this is a better quality vehicle is it
as fast as the model s probably not
i think the model s is you know the
fastest 3.1 right the model s i think is
1.9 the plaid or something like that
but the quality of this car
is dramatically better
and now tesla's gonna have to fight
companies
they don't have the range yet
but they know how to make cars far far
better this is a better car in my mind
quality you it's very very tough to beat
this
okay
next vehicle
porsche
tycam okay
this is a better car they they make
better cars
they don't have the range yet right
225 miles or 282 with the performance
battery plus okay this is a better car
is it as fast no
uh let's see this one this is 4.8
seconds this is 3.8
3.9 the gts is 3.5
the turbo is 3
3.1 the turbo s is 2.6
okay so
the model s plaid is
1.990 to 60 but who cares this is a much
higher quality vehicle
and then lastly
maybe the best of these i don't know
is the mercedes eqs 580 4matic sedan
of these three probably the best quality
out of all of them
um
when it comes to build quality
and just the feel of the entire vehicle
so
is it time to abandon tesla
i i have no idea
i have no idea but what i can tell you
is all along tesla's advantage has been
been a first mover and having the range
what's the range on this thing
uh i don't even know
yeah i'm not even sure what would it
even say i'm not sure oh electric range
here it is oh to be announced okay so we
don't even know yet so um
yeah i think that uh if you don't care
about the automated driving which i can
tell you is okay but you know it's i
don't know
um i think that these three vehicles
are better quality vehicles than the
model s and i do expect that over time
uh they're gonna they're gonna build
market share i i think that that that's
basically it okay that's uh that's the
full story i wanna say thanks to
jen here
for gifting and resubbing as well as
twitching mangoes for the three twitch
subs very much appreciate that also want
to say thanks to aaron [ __ ] day who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code obama
and his new member number 16. okay super
chat's coming in compare the model 3 and
y to things like the bolt and leaf no
i'm comparing the s
so we were looking at the s compared to
these three vehicles and i think that
the other three are probably better
david the eevee powertrain matters most
legacy autos fall far short
uh yeah so listen here here's the thing
all of these cars if you look at where
where do i charge these cars
the answers are still not very
convenient
right now what is keeping
tesla's advantage in addition to having
the biggest range is the supercharger
network with these things
maybe you can find you know like 110
kilowatt or whatever charger
but you're still talking about a charge
time that doesn't make sense if you're
going to be driving anything other than
around town so that there's no doubt
that tesla still has an advantage there
guys i don't i have no loyalty i don't
i'm just telling you like it is it's
funny there's people saying david you're
being too loyal to tesla and people
saying david you're not giving tesla
enough credit i'm just telling it like
it is guys that's all i'm doing okay
everybody relax everybody relax um other
super chats coming in sir i agree on the
breville great machine there's a cheaper
version without the grinder right
david people tell me sir if we can just
cut 11 780 twitch subs the pacman show
may be the most sub channel that's what
they tell me i've read the same
getting pfizer booster today even though
we're still learning about the variant
oh yeah there's no reason not to get it
at this point
very very important message
uh
okay good so we got that out of the way
and let me see if we're ready for the
first conversation
all right we are going to be speaking
with destiny and vosh today but
separately all right let me get to a
couple of other different things we did
want to go over this new um lauren bobo
bobert thing she gave i don't know if it
was a speech or stand-up comedy
somewhere over the weekend it was all
really weird and she said some horrible
things take a look at this actually i
have an ohana story for
so uh the other night on the house floor
was not the my first jihad squad moment
uh so
i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers and he and i are we're
leaving the capitol we're going back to
my office and we get an elevator and i
see a capitol police officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see threat all over
his face and he's reaching and i'm like
the door's shutting like i can't i can't
open it like what's happening
i look to my left and there she is
ilhan omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
so that's a suicide bomb joke i guess um
not particularly funny
but um
i guess it counts as comedy in in her
world
so we only had one floor to go like uh
did i say it why not i looked over and i
said oh look the jihad squad decided to
show up for work today
don't worry it's just your staffers on
twitter that talk for her she she's not
tough in person she doesn't yes
so
okay um i guess there were other things
she said also
that were tweeted about i think patriot
takes had them
let me see here
yeah here's some other moments from this
thing
because
of this
piece of crap
in the white house
okay
and he says lauren
what can i do for you
i said mr president i'm really glad you
asked
i would love if you came to my district
in the spring
yeah
that's what we might be looking forward
to trump campaigning with lauren
beaubert in the spring
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so
we are working on getting president
trump to our district in the spring and
we want this to be the biggest rally
that he has ever had in colorado
[Applause]
that'll be exciting
later that night when i was with
president trump we had a room of about
600 people
he started talking about this
failed regime
this illegal failed regime
and i got a little chant going
the whole room
[Applause]
i'm like getting goosebumps from from
the cringe
let's go brandon
so president trump waits until this is
over and he looks around and he says you
know
i like the first version better
what a funny guy huh and i was proud
my first
duty in congress to object to the
certification
of those electoral college results
because they were fraudulent
[Applause]
okay
i asked him what else can we be doing he
said everything you're doing what you're
doing is exactly what you need to be
doing objecting on january 6 was
absolutely the role of congress those
states
that illegally mailed out millions of
ballots
changed election laws
outside of the state legislature which
is totally legal we've already talked
about it that was unconstitutional
and illegal
and now
because
congress
didn't have enough guts
to actually do their job correctly
now we're chasing 10 000 ballots here
and 20 000 ballots there no we're not
the election's over and the last time i
was with president trump well i did have
a fancy little red dress to show off
[Applause]
i was sitting in his office in florida
the new white house
[Applause]
that's where everybody seems to be i
don't know
wow
it's really really insane
um
actually i mean it's it's it's crazy
they're just they're not gonna they're
how long will they go i guess until the
next election i don't know
um okay
let's get to
all right let's let's get to the first
of two conversations we're gonna first
talk to
uh stephen kenneth destiny bennell ii we
are gonna try to clear the air
okay guys let's see if we can do that
i'm gonna try calling him right now
and see what we've got going on
um
guys i think this is working
steven
hello how are you
i'm doing great david deepak
pac-man how are you doing let me
introduce to my audience if you're not
familiar with them we're going to be
speaking with the most prominent
cuban-american twitch streamer of our
time stephen kenneth
destiny
bennell ii welcome back steven
thanks for having me back on what's up
oh i think your discord might be using
or the incorrect microphone or it sounds
like a webcam microphone yeah i think
that is where you mean what you're
hearing me through
yeah
yeah let me see if i can change look i'm
going to try changing something standby
yeah if you click user settings and go
to um oh no i know it sometimes just
comes through muffled is that better oh
yeah now you're good to go okay good
good good and my audience can still hear
me everybody can hear me still
uh oh no my audience can no longer hear
me
oh my audience can hear me okay and you
can still hear me right stephen yep loud
and clear beautiful
well listen i think that there is a lot
of clearing the air here that needs to
be done
okay now i do want to say first and
foremost that
since our last conversation
i have received uh dozens and dozens of
emails tweets
links to various um
reddit threads and
i am not going to be sort of like
addressing anything in particular in the
sense that every sentiment was expressed
ranging from
never waste your time with destiny again
and
destiny should never waste his time with
you again like the full gamut was the
reaction of stuff from people the whole
spectrum exactly exactly all right
so i mean i think listen
i think tempers have sort of cooled off
a little bit since the other day is that
fair to say
well i don't think i had a big temper at
all but sure
yeah what about it
well let's not even get into that uh and
and so
let's not get into an argument as to
whether tempers flared let's skip that
argument you don't want to get into a
meta argument about the arguments no
let's see if we can avoid a three layers
removed argument at this point in time
um
i think that uh
a lot of things were said
okay and
it's i i was not expecting that it would
become a sort of point counterpoint
thing i don't know if you were expecting
it
uh i don't you know i go into every
conversation with no expectations and
then every conversation is just an
absolute joy because i never know what
to expect oh okay all right so like i
mean in all seriousness
but you felt good about the conversation
well no i thought it was a horrible
conversation oh okay of course all right
okay good so we're it sounds like we're
both on the same page about that that's
good no i mean i would i would expect it
to be for us to both feel away yeah it
would be easy i think to just to just
explain away that the conversation was a
disaster by each of us saying it was a
disaster merely because the other person
said xyz which i don't agree with which
i feel like would get us into the exact
same circle
probably yeah yeah so maybe
like
i'm sort of happy to say um
man what am i even happy to say i don't
know that i'm happy to say anything i'm
trying to
not a single thing to be grateful for on
the day after thanksgiving yeah not one
thing to be happy about i think that um
i mean i guess okay let me do one thing
where i can let me let me at least
clarify one thing one thing that people
did write to me which i ended up feeling
bad about because of how it was
perceived was when i asked if you were
mildly autistic at the end of the
conversation there were two reactions
that made me feel really bad one was
that people said
i was i was used i was using that as an
insult but i would never i mean it's
like saying i'm insulting people for
being diabetic
i'm not gonna you know
there's no i'm not there's no laughing
at medical conditions for me it was not
meant as an insult it was not meant like
anything like that so if it came out i
want to apologize sure first of all i
don't do apologies i don't care okay uh
but
diabetic isn't the same thing right
well it's stigmatized that's the whole
point i mean that's right it's seen
totally differently but for me it's like
i wouldn't laugh at any medical
condition
sure but the the i think the issue with
bringing up the autistic thing is it
appears that you're trying to undermine
everything that was previously said
by pointing to some so it would be the
equivalent of me asking at the end like
david do you have a learning disability
like it would be like that type of thing
and then my goal is to impeach your
character based upon the answers you
give to that line of questions fair
right fair and so to the extent that
that's how it came off that is that was
not my intention and it was
it may have been an inappropriately
timed question i will i will stipulate
to that but it was not a joke of any
kind and for me autism is not funny
okay is that fair
yeah if you feel that yeah i can i'm not
here to tell you how you can feel about
things so sure okay all right good
um
what else yeah i mean i don't know in
terms of other stuff you know i guess i
was in one sense i was a little bit
surprised and i don't know if it was
surprised in from the standpoint of
positive or the standpoint of negative
that in the aftermath
i've people were linking me to
quite literally multi-page almost
line-by-line analyses of the
conversation we had
which i don't know if it's like wow
people care enough about what was said
that they took that much time to do it
or maybe some people are a little too
wrapped up in the in our in our
conversation which at the end of the day
is
i don't know i don't know how meaningful
our conversation should be to just the
people at large you
uh well know
mean i would hope that my conversations
with people are pretty meaningful
because that's the whole reason i do
what i do is so that my words have
meaning to the people that are listening
right i think that's a it's pretty fair
to expect that people are going to try
to find meaning in the conversations we
have with others now
as a public figure right yeah that seems
fair that seems fair so you were not
surprised at the amount of like analysis
that was done
no i don't think so okay fair fair
um
all right and i mean listen at the end
of the day
now with the hindsight of the verdict
the verdict was
basically as expected i mean i thought
that it was conceivable that there would
be
some guilties on them on the minor
charges but two of the minor charges
didn't even make it to the jury
uh so i think you and i both agree that
there was nothing surprising about the
verdict is that fair
yeah but i mean the verdict was never
really the that's the boring part right
well i don't know about that i mean i
think that if the verdict is different
it would be number one surprising
i don't know that written house gets the
hero welcome from
trump and tucker and everybody if the
verdict is different i mean i do think
the verdict is meaningful
um i feel like the verdict is
meaningless because i think it's more
interesting that the interesting
conversation was how the verdict was
arrived at it's kind of like saying um
to use a charged example you know black
people tend to commit more crime in the
united states than white people like
that fact isn't interesting the
interesting discussion is well why is
that the case right some people on the
very far right will say culture or very
far right will say genetics people on
the left will say socioeconomic factors
environmental conditions so like that
that argument is the more interesting
part not necessarily that factoid so
when we talk about like the verdict of
the case in my opinion at least um you
know whether or not he's innocent or
guilty isn't the interesting part the uh
the conversations are more like if he
was black would he have made it to trial
would the cops have killed him was the
judge being fair like was the
prosecution being earnest um you know
could a another person afford that
defense like i think these are the more
interesting questions rather than just
saying like oh well here's the verdict i
think in my opinion do you feel like you
got interesting answers to the more
interesting questions
well that's where all of my discussion
has been to yeah i've always told people
that you should never be too invested in
the verdict of a jury case i mean we can
hope for things but i mean jury cases
can go anyway right
either direction we have no idea
fair all right so in terms of your
coverage arc are you moving on from that
case or are you going to continue doing
content related to it
um i've i hope to move on it already
like has dominated so much of like the
past like two weeks i think of what i've
done because everybody's talking about
it but i mean on to the next thing right
what's your reaction to um
the hero's welcome by trump and stuff
like that
i mean it's pretty cringe but it's to be
expected um i mean especially when
people on the left like are pushing so
hard in the other direction i mean it's
more or less what i would expect if one
group of people is going to [ __ ] on
somebody then they're probably going to
be welcomed by the other group of people
uh that's interesting so you believe
he's been lionized by the right because
he's been attacked by the left
i think that plays into it now
it probably would have happened to some
extent anyway but i mean if enough
people are going to make somebody out to
be a villain you can find a group of
people that'll make that same person out
to be a hero i gotcha i think that both
both ends definitely play into that what
was your thought on the arbory verdict
uh i didn't i didn't follow that trial
so i'm really hesitant to say anything
on it but i don't think anything was
ever presented that would have made me
think that that should have gone any any
way differently i don't believe that any
of those three guys witnessed directly
that person committing a crime um so i
don't know if they had the right to to
chase him down and and confront him to
do their citizens arrest or whatever
i don't think that three grown men it
didn't seem like he had a weapon or
anything at the time right so there was
no reason their life was in danger so i
don't know why like a gun would have
been brought out um
everything for how those verdicts played
out seemed to me like they probably
should have been that way but i say that
cautiously because i didn't follow that
trial or look at all the evidence for
that but these are just like the things
that i've read the snippets and
everything i've read why why
one of the first things you said is
interesting why were you
much so much more interested in the
written house trial than rather than
this one
um because i thought that this trial was
like pretty it felt to me and again i'm
like very cautiously saying this guy
didn't watch but it felt to me like this
one was pretty obvious the whole time
you had like um there were three dudes
in a truck they saw a black guy jogging
they thought he was a [ __ ] criminal
and then they chased him down and they
essentially ended up executing him with
his feet with a shotgun that's that
seems insane to me it seems really bad i
don't think i could be wrong but i don't
think anybody was defending the three
white guys i don't think any maybe there
were a few crazies on the internet but
for the most part it seemed like that
they were like universally panned as
like the bad guys oh that's interesting
in other words you thought that
the verdict was so much more obvious in
this one that it was less interesting to
you
yeah i think so yeah the only thing i
saw was like tim poole quibbling over
like what a citizen's arrest was but
otherwise
it seemed like nobody was gonna go out
to defend those guys hey by the way
speaking of tim did you see this recent
video where he was with um alex jones in
studio
um
probably not i saw one where it was like
tim paul alex jones and a bunch of
people joe rogan and stuff and some in a
trailer yeah no no no not that one i
mean the one where he was like in alex
jones studio he somehow manages to
crowbar into the first two minutes three
times that he has a girlfriend which is
so funny because i don't know if you saw
that video like a year ago that had a
very in-cell feel where he was saying
like i'm single and it's like clearly
every it clearly it's not me so it's
clearly everybody else
oh gotcha okay i thought you were gonna
refer to the there was some video where
i think he talked about how he can go on
tinder for like two minutes and like
pick up any girly once and blah blah
blah was like okay oh no i never i
didn't see that one i didn't see that
one yeah no it's it's worth seeing it's
very interesting he seems almost like
smitten with alex jones it's very
interesting
okay the other funny thing is alex jones
seems to continue referring to him as a
leftist even on the thing like here's a
leftist i'm willing to have on
wait who oh he refers to tim poole as a
leftist yeah although then he hedges by
going you're not even necessarily on the
left you're just sort of like a normal
pro freedom american or something like
it's it's like very very weird the whole
thing is weird and the i also don't know
if you've noticed but like when alex
jones has a guest on and you see alex
jones in the reaction shot he seems very
bored with what his guests are saying
like he doesn't really seem to even pay
attention
yeah i mean that he's
he's a character um i feel like there's
this whole group of people that
it became like a trend to not call
yourself a conservative even though you
were a conservative in everything but
name only like i i don't know if i would
say dave rubin started that but
he kept there
yeah or why i left the left but i'm not
really a conservative but you are in
every single way i don't yeah i don't
know why people yeah yeah yeah no it's
crazy
uh well listen i uh
i i don't want to make this an
if-apology day but to the extent that i
did anything wrong notice i'm not saying
to the extent that i offended anyone to
the extent that i did anything wrong
i do apologize to you and your audience
for the other day
yeah you're it's listen we don't care
about apologies here david all we care
about is the love we have for each other
and nothing is going to overcome that
okay my fellow gusano in arms all right
oh god um now let me check in with you
one oh here's also one thing i wanted to
mention
you know i used to be banned on twitch
i'm not anymore so we're all in the
clear but right now we're observing your
stream with uh i'm logged out and
there's a really interesting thing i'm
looking at in the bottom left which says
destiny viewers also watch john
jerka
david pakman and something called chud
logic what are john jerka and chud logic
john is uh just i
can't really put in that's kind of like
asking like what does asset feel like i
can't really put into words that stream
you just have to experience that for
yourself and then chad logic is a uh
british i think he does like kind of
like political commentary stuff and are
they on the left or the right
john circa uh defies political spectrum
analysis and child logic is probably
like left i'd say
and then the other two that it says are
like your viewers also watch in addition
to my show is echo rules and xander hall
do those ring a bell
icon rules i i don't want to say
anything mean about her because she's
usually nice to me but she seems a
little insane left person um xander hall
is
i i don't know
he's a political person he seems okayish
okay all right all right very good
uh well listen um
i'm glad to be able to clear the air
with you and i'll pay pal you the money
i agreed on a little bit later
okay and are you is it looking like
you're going to be in la in the second
half of december or what's it looking
like
uh well my lease is officially up on the
20th so it'll depend on when you're here
but i don't even know if i'll be here
we'll see oh my god i get in i think on
the 19th
oh wow i'm almost for sure not gonna be
here then and and you're gonna be in oh
no no i get in the 17th i get in the
17th
okay just highly unlikely then and when
you think you'll be where are you saying
where you will be here i feel like i'll
be gone in the first week of december
but we'll see you know and and you're
heading down down south
uh
am i is my oh yeah of course yes i get
yeah miami i guess okay feels weird to
say i live in l.a and i'm going down
south but
i guess sure and are you saying whether
you're doing like
miami proper or miami beach
um you know i was gonna do miami beach
uh you know there's not a lot of units
available to get anywhere and stuff so
did you say there aren't unix available
units available oh you oh like an
apartment unit oh my god that was like
what like what did you do what exactly
are you doing down there yeah yeah
there's an abundance of unix like that
wouldn't even make sense of course that
wouldn't make sense um yeah but it's
some i don't i think it's miami proper
but i don't know um yeah but yeah and is
marina coming with us or
um i would hope so unless she hasn't
told me something but
she's gonna tie to me now because she's
on a k1 so if she leaves me she's kicked
out of the country forever so she's a
slave wait you guys you guys are married
well yeah that's what the whole process
has been moving towards yeah oh i didn't
realize that i know so you've been
you've you're legally married at this
time well not legally married she's here
right now in k1 we have like 60 days to
fill up the paperwork you get married oh
okay okay okay
yeah i you know what would be really
great if you know how sometimes you have
to go to these meetings where they like
want to make sure you're really a couple
and stuff like that
you've heard of this like immigration
officials yeah we've already done this
oh yeah it would be great if there's
another meeting
if you bring a screenshot of when you
guys were in copenhagen streaming and
there's like a table of people behind
you and they're furiously staring at you
it would be great if you presented that
as the evidence that you're really
together to immigration officials i
would love that
wait i totally
don't understand
i don't remember when you were in
college oh god never mind no no i
understand now
holy yikes that was the most cringe
moment i've ever streamed in my entire
life oh my god
oh my god yeah i know what you're
talking about that's a historic moment
in streaming that's a historic moment
for me that's when i committed to twitch
after that i was like i need to be on
this platform
jesus that um apparently the interview
is really easy or melina said it was
like they didn't like every time i read
on the internet they're like oh they
might ask you crazy things like you know
like what is the favorite flavor of
coffee creamer that this purple but
apparently they asked like three or four
questions like oh do you guys love each
other you chill like oh cool and then i
was like whatever so did you have to
bring documents that you guys are like
together for real
yeah but i don't even know how much they
mattered but we had like it was like a
50 page [ __ ] thing of like our
screenshots of our instagram history
like photos where we've traveled an
airplane it's a whole bunch of [ __ ] do
you have like a foreign wife or
do i no no i'm foreign i'm the foreign
one
did you have to do this process no no no
no i uh i just signed up for a passport
when i was 17 and that i got citizenship
that way because my parents were already
citizens at the time
oh gosh you gotcha okay it's a whole
different process
all right well steven listen i'll check
with you i'll ask one more question i'm
curious because i just got home
literally four hours ago when i'm
streaming now um is this uh is this new
variant the new variant is it anything
to be concerned about you mean omicron
oh is it omicron i thought they were
going with new i guess they're going
with omicron
okay man that's just a really scary name
i know i know the name doesn't bode well
here's my take on it from looking at you
know what everybody's
all various experts have been saying
it's called a variant of concern because
we should be concerned but it's not a
variant of panic we don't yet we won't
know for two weeks if it actually evades
vaccines and at the at this time there's
no evidence it's more deadly it's like
you just gotta wait you know
okay sure i don't know if i read this or
if i'm making this overhead but i
thought i saw a headline that said that
the united states is looking to ban all
travel from african countries soon in a
week i haven't seen that
okay i'll look for maybe south africa
but i don't know
uh-huh no okay oh it was just south
africa you're right the united states
will shoot for from non-u.s citizens
from south africa and seven oh and seven
other countries starting monday so maybe
some other afghanistan that's probably
it that sounds right yeah i mean listen
we just got to see what's going on did
you get a third dose
uh i'm scheduled too i think in two days
oh okay and what do you know what you're
getting
uh i think i sign up for the madonna one
because i think it's more yeah
it's sort of like a uh
you know like the ga the prisoner's
dilemma and game theory where it's like
no matter what you think the other
person's going to do here's what you
should do
with the vaccines it's like no matter
what your first vaccine was
you should get the the modern booster
that's like it's the same thing yeah oh
yeah i'm going to say that i think i
think the moderna and the pfizer shots
are the same it's just that the modern
one was like three times the dose so i
think that's why the uh um data is
panned out better for it yeah i don't
know but i know it's more i don't know
about three times but yeah i think it's
three times because the modern booster
is half the dose of the original shot
but i think it's still more than the
pfizer one right right but yeah yeah
okay
all right very good well listen it's
good to check in i'll be in touch and uh
you know with peace and love to the dgg
community and uh please stop posting
about me in destiny's subreddit okay
okay i love everybody all right talk to
you soon thanks love you bye
all right folks there is stephen
kenneth
destiny
bonnell ii great to check in with him
and to clear the air
um and a little bit later today
we are going to be
chatting with ian vosh ian vosh will be
coming up a little bit later today so
please stand by for that that's actually
just about 10 minutes from now so
there's a lot a lot a lot going on today
i want to say thank you to lobster lover
for signing up via twitch prime we are
unbanned from twitch today is a great
day to re-up your twitch prime
subscription i also want to say thanks
to bennett dirkman who just signed up on
my website joinedpakman.com and his new
member number 18.
and nikita cheney just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
obama
[Music]
and his new member number 19
uh i implore you my friends today is a
great day to grab a twitch prime sub or
to sign up on my website a patreon
pledges do count double today and i
would love for you to do that uh joy kit
just signed up via twitch prime and is
number 20. thanks joykit joykit says
five months try not to get banned again
believe me i'm making every effort i'm
making every effort not to get banned
again
uh
okay all right good let's get to
some voicemails there are so so many
and i want to
see what we can do to work through some
of them um let's just just kind of see
what what there is here
why are they even talking about this in
court
rosenbaum and written house okay i'm
gonna try to skip written house stuff a
lot of these are old and like the
trial's over so i just don't i don't
want to get us bogged down
with this sort of stuff here's one about
drone footage
hey david it's your boy matsubasu i
wanted to know if you had an official
ruling when it comes to the warm
calzones
and if you had
a specific preference for
recommendations when it comes to
places that serve calzones
for your preferred
uh toppings and films okay i i tend to
like to go with a veggie calzone i think
artichokes black olives sliced not whole
olives i mean we're not savages but
sliced olives i think are good
uh i tend to be more of a veggie guy on
the calzone standpoint david get me from
philly
so my boy johnny dougherty that's the
dude that i was referring to to move
from philly to washington township he
wants to speak to you david i think he's
going to say your voicemail be looking
for it but as far as uh kyle 12 well
first of all why am i still
banned
band
what even is shadow bit right
that's the first that's the next
question
so
i think that a lot of the voices that
were saying like not to get vaccinated
and like the people who were really loud
about
you know like you don't own me and like
that kind of stuff
i feel like those voices are like kind
of starting to like fizzle down though
and
as okay i don't know about that
uh let's say
hi david sir i'm curious about your
opinion on something republicans
in the past have often been kind of um
accused
of speaking particularly to each other i
can barely hear that guy and it's
completely completely completely cranked
up
um
here's something about from a sam cedar
viewer
dave sir i am a whistleblower it's been
deep undercover as a uh sam cedar
subscriber for years
where it's finally come down
that he will be holding a uh
insurrection of his own sorts on january
6th
18th
at uh
at the
capital of davidpak okay it's not funny
it's not it's not a good joke it's just
not funny
um all right let's see what else we've
got
let's see if we can get to something
relevant here
oh by the way if you're just joining us
we're going to be speaking to uh to to
vosh very very soon
hey david it's eric from mass you still
haven't figured out this whole thing is
fake yet dude
i mean they just want you to keep taking
shots forever hook you into a qr more
and more shorts
tell you what to buy and sell
um have this little card you walk around
with so you can eat pizza when you want
they'll tell you when you're walking
around with a piece of cod that's weird
that's really strange there one's very
strange
what are your thoughts
the voicemail line is really collapsing
hey david my name's casey from alabama
i'm calling because even though i
identify as a conservative for the most
part i do have some
left-leaning progressive sympathies and
a
leftward stance on some issues uh thank
you very much for all of your content
because you have shown me a different
side of many issues that i've never
considered
however
one problem that i have with your show
is that you seem to spend a lot of time
talking about trump
uh trump has been out of office for
several months now yeah we actually did
the numbers on it and there's very
relatively few trump clips
um so you know we've addressed it the
guy still owns the republican party
they're all praying for you know praying
to at the altar of trump and
uh i think last week it was like 150
clips and there were like
four trump clips or something we did the
number at some point
um you know it i don't know it's how we
we've dealt with that before
bailly and perfect david peckman
first-time caller i'd like to know
why american airlines are not requiring
vaccination as a condition
for flying domestically
it seems to me even as a vaccinated
person
if i'm sitting next to someone who's
carrying
i'm gonna catch it even more both
wearing masks keep the masks on the
whole time
again i'm vaccinated i think i'm sitting
next to a somebody who's infected
i'm gonna catch
the coven
and
so i'm not willing to fly anymore until
uh domestic airlines require vaccination
pass back i doubt that they are going to
do that okay i just i just don't believe
they're going to do that here is uh
let's see uh-oh whenever i see one two
three four five six
voicemails in a row from the same person
i'm always curious let's check it out
yes david this odds i was trying to tell
you oops okay all right our oz has oz is
off the wagon and i am not
we're being really really careful
okay
hi david how are you i love the show and
i think you're great
anyways
i had a theory about hassan [ __ ] not
responding to your calls
i think he's probably upset because you
still talk to destiny he probably thinks
you're on team destiny after all that
gusano stuff
but anyways thanks for the great show
it's not that hassan is ignoring my
calls i sent him a a message
uh was it twitter or discord saying hey
i'm going to be in l.a let's get
together let me go over and do you know
i can like weed your garden at the new
house for you or something and he didn't
write back so let's all let's all relax
it's not that he's ignoring my calls
um let's see what else we've got here
we're going to be speaking to vosh soon
oh in fact let me send you a message
we are going to be speaking to ian vosh
in a bit
okay stand by everybody
i do want to say thanks to geeks nation
and dingleberry 69 for the twitch subs
numbers 21 and 22 today uh today's a
great day to re-up your twitch sub
it is a great uh great day to do it all
right let's listen to a few more of
these voicemails while we stand by for
our conversation with vosh
see what else we've got here
uh
a bunch of thanksgiving messages
but i don't know that a lot of these are
going to be great for you
hey david it's not
i just saw the boner show where pat says
he is going to go to colombia for the
thanksgiving weekend yeah it's too bad
that the news didn't come sooner since
then pedro from colombia has called in
to give pat
some tips on what to do or eat you know
yeah except we don't know where pedro is
even from that's the thing
uh a lot of like destiny attack
voicemails but in order to keep things
going with him i don't know that i'm
gonna play
them good
day david pakman and happy thanksgiving
okay
thank you i very much appreciate that i
uh got a nice um happy thanksgiving
message from jimmy from philly
um
what else
uh
we did have another one from whitney but
we're gonna we're gonna skip that for
now
yeah just kind of a lot of mediocre
voicemails maybe because of the holiday
weekend
hey david it's eric from mass i know you
must have missed this i mean i probably
just didn't see it or something all this
stuff going on but uh can you do a story
on uh
sizer uh going to the courts and
um asking for a 55-year hold on the
results of the trials for the uh
coveted 19
uh gene therapy oops i mean that scene
man i never know what eric is talking
about it's just uh it's always
very very strange
uh oh here's vosh
let's see
what he's saying
popular for a long time but i don't
think it's really common for a game to
be
not popular in the sense that it's
played for a really long time but okay
uh we'll let him do his thing and then
when he's ready when he's ready to start
then we will we will get started
hey david it's eric from math uh you
nailed it dude you're right who is
written house to talk about self defense
that'd be like throwing a michael jordan
or larry bird and asking about the nba
basketball
oh my god um i want to say thanks to
bowflex man and
youngopx for the twitch prime subs
numbers 23 and 24.
um
let's do let's do the following up until
we start talking to vosh website
memberships will count double if you use
the coupon code obama obama you can see
it over my head and it saves you 68
and also they will count double up until
we start the conversation with vosh
uh which is uh still i guess not not
happening quite yet we're just going to
listen to a couple more of your
voicemails
before we speak to
vosh uh
let's see
what else we've got
but could they possibly just be
listening to like dumb women because of
their horniness oh my god okay we're
gonna get away from that let's see what
else we've got here
uh
yeah david i'm from wisconsin and there
are signs up all over wisconsin that
dumbass donald trump is running in 2024
just thought you might want to know oh
no the signs that say trump 2024 they're
not saying trump is running they're
saying they want trump to run
um
yeah
hey david it's matthew from las vegas
so i'm listening to the newest episode
and obviously we've been seeing what's
happening in the world regarding the
coronavirus and mandates and as a jew
from south florida now living in las
vegas
uh
could you maybe explain to me
why
the far right extremists the
conspiratorial nut cases and all these
inhumane insane people oh hold on a
second
we're actually going to talk to ian vosh
now hold on a second
hello hello
hello yourself uh david uh the pac-man
pac-man happy to be talking to you it's
great to be on with you again
uh truly an honor how you doing i'm
doing well i'm doing well how was your
thanksgiving
it was great we um
i threw a contrivance got to see my
family earlier in the month so i didn't
see them this time we just um a
contrivance is that legal
uh shouldn't be i got baited into
heading down to la for a jubilee
appearance but it turns out it got
cancelled after i booked the flight so
my parents are there anyway you know so
oh i see do you say where you're based
regularly
oh i'm in seattle oh okay oh so
literally down the coast
yeah gotcha gotcha and what are you on
planes are you like doing full n95 or
just like one of the cloth masks
um just uh just a you know a a
rotating series of disposable masks i
never found a cloth one that looks good
with a beard i don't know if i ever
could find one that looks good with a
beard oh i say i say yes
are you like when you're on a plane do
you feel like you're more at risk of
catching it or on a plane you feel safe
um
honestly i don't feel that at risk on a
plane because it's you know airports and
airplanes are one of the few
institutions that actually seem to take
seriously the whole wiping down every
surface that kind of thing
um
yeah i don't know i feel more at risk at
like a grocery mart that i do on a plane
but that's just oh that's interesting
see i i have a bit of a different
perspective i mean i don't feel too at
risk on the plane but not because
they're wiping down surfaces because it
seems like that actually
is not really how people are catching
this it's more just like you're near
someone who has it and you're breathing
the same air but because of the
very high efficacy
air filtration and mandatory masks
that's a good point yeah i forgot about
the air filtration they'd have to keep
that standard up there i do still hate
flying though honestly kovat is the
least of my worries i just hate
heights so
it's just um
i'm not a big fan um you know as for the
concept do you medicate on the flight
uh no no i i try not to i know people
who have to take ambien or whatever but
i usually just stock up on um
on on audio you know audio books i
haven't listened to or podcasts or
whatever the hell else and uh just try
to live through it i gotcha yeah yeah no
i know people who take uh sedatives when
they fly stuff like that
or they just drink if in first class
right they usually just give you wine
you can get enough of that i mean that
might help sure oh are you flying in
first class
i've only floated in first class once
somebody else was paying for it and i
didn't like them so i just went with
first class and uh booked it to them oh
that's a good move that's a beautiful
move
yeah it's um it's the the only time i
would you know afford myself that
indulges if if economy is good enough
for bernie it's good enough for me right
well i'm seeing pictures of him up front
too but i guess that's a story for a
different day
he varies a little bit getting
complacent in his old age um you um so
are you now on thanksgi are you uh do
you eat turkey is that a big thing for
you i hate i know turkey's like the
worst meat
no i um no we well okay this time we
just had mac and cheese it was
disgustingly rich mac and cheese i got
some tarts and some pies you know um but
normally no i'm more of a stuffing
bread roll pecan pie uh you know food
coma type of guy
oh you uh yeah i had some turkey i had
some turkey uh i mean it's like you know
it's always kind of dry and like you're
really counting on it's really about the
quality of the
um gravy quite frankly that because the
you know turkey breast it's like it is
what it is you know
yeah there's only
so much you can do to choose it up i
think did you did you what what would
you celebrate with like uh
oh fit with family with family
okay gotcha yeah yeah just uh yeah it
was just me and my roommates um but you
know
the family uh you know very flexible
term whoever you're with uh can be your
family on thanksgiving it's a magic of
the holiday are your roommates um
sort of like i'm guessing you're the
most famous of the people you live with
is that a fair assumption
yeah i guess so do they take are they
resentful of your fame
uh i maybe they would be if i made them
pay rent but honest to god i feel like
they're getting the uh i feel like
they're getting the good end of the deal
on this one oh you pay for their rent
that that only seems fair right you know
like i don't know
i don't know what this what the
circumstances are
i would i would never i'd feel like such
an [ __ ] you know like uh you know oh
yeah you know you've got you've got this
arrangement that and the other and we're
all going to split it three ways and
then i you know watch them like pull out
the the coins they've got buried in the
back of their wallet to try to make rent
do you own the place is that the
situation no no oh you don't know we're
all renting you're all renting okay
you're not like rent seeking or
something like that
i know as far as my audience knows you
know we're all renting i would never
become a landlord wouldn't yeah as far
as my audience knows okay i got you very
very good we'll check the property
records later and determine exactly the
arrangement there
um just try to catch me yeah
uh okay good well so oh on the flying
thing i did want to ask is it do you not
like the discomfort of it or is it
you're worried the plane will crash
um
i think it's shifted more with time
because when i was younger i was just
terrified of crashing um and i still
don't like that you know but
now i think the physical discomfort is
the worst bit by far okay um the the
seats are so tiny and i'm a decently big
guy you know oh is that right how tall a
guy are you
i'm i'm six too and i've got wide hips
so they they bridge up against the um
the the little armrests like on the
sides but you can't lift them if you're
next to a stranger of course oh i had no
idea you were six too because in the in
the infamous picture of you sitting next
to stephen kenneth destiny bennell ii
you guys are sitting down and it's hard
to tell relative size
yeah and you know out of respect i try
to like you know lean down a little bit
like yeah yeah
you're slouching down just to not
impress people too yeah i know what
you're saying that's good that's polite
yeah yeah just common etiquette i think
i think so um
the la the last f
before we talk about anything serious
the last flight that i had was was
utterly miserable i had i had a headache
the the duration of the return flight
but um there the woman directly in front
of me is older lady who didn't speak
english only spanish and she actually
had like a medical emergency she
couldn't breathe that well so you know
they brought out the oxygen tank they
did the holes they're a doctor on board
thing and i actually with a headache got
to like have 40 minutes of people
swarming next to me like elbowing me in
the side of the head as they shuffle
around the woman directly in front she
was fine she was fine you know now when
they ask for a doctor
on a plane i wonder if people stand up
and say i'm a doctor but i mean i'm a
doctor in sociology or in that context
is it known that they only want a
medical doctor
you know i'm actually really proud of my
uh flight guests because it seems like
every one of them got the the
connotation you know they knew they
wanted a medical doctor you know one of
them stood up and was like yeah you know
i've got a i've got a doctorate in in
mathematics
yeah uh this shit's work
uh so i'm proud of them maybe maybe the
next flight though it's funny because
there everybody knows exactly what
they're looking for my dad has had
situations where he actually is a doctor
but a psychiatrist and he'll wait
because he knows when they're asking for
a doctor
they'd rather it not be a psychiatrist
so he'll usually wait but then if it's
like nobody steps forward then he'll be
like i'm a doctor okay yeah because
that's better than nothing exactly it's
better than yeah that's
you still a few definitely a few steps
up above the average person sure i mean
it is a medical doctor but you know yeah
yeah but you know you could probably
like i don't know look at people's
eyeballs and get something from that
their state of being how they're feeling
i don't know it's it's something well
this thing was very simple it was
someone was having a food allergic
reaction of some kind and they had so
you don't really see shrimp that often
on planes but they had shrimp and then
it was like oh i think i might be
allergic to shrimp and my dad just had
to say i have to find out
do you guys have
benadryl in your like medical kit and
they were like yeah and he was like i'd
probably give him a benadryl i don't
know and then the guy was fine
okay well good good thing it didn't
require one of those uh epipens right
exactly exactly yeah
so listen what are we talking about
today
oh um
my my as my resident favorite uh liberal
i wanted to talk with you a little bit
about rittenhouse oh okay all right
um yeah so i mean we you cover the trial
obviously all the trial that i saw was
through your stream beautiful i know you
were in there leaving very powerful
super chats
yeah um
and you were you were there uh very
powerfully leaving the stream for hours
at a time collecting revenue uh well i
did have work to do i had to plan my
next show you know
ah oh you know well not all live
streamers have that privilege you know i
actually have to i rush back from the
bathroom after peeing uh to keep the
viewers but no yeah it's fair uh
um okay so
as for the legal outcome you know i i
get it uh i i understand where
you know where that all came from uh
morally still don't think that she
should have been there i don't think
that's a she
he oh sorry sorry sorry i i've read so
many memes about written house
transitioning to own the libs uh that's
affecting me um but you know i i've seen
how that will win have you had the
pleasure of seeing the tucker carlson
interview yes i have
what did you think of that
well i mean listen um
oh god so so i i feel like i have to
issue 10 disclaimers like the opinion
i'm going to give has nothing to do with
the verdict i get the verdict that's the
verdict i expected etc so so like i'm
just going to talk about the interview
as an interview
um
i thought it was part of the predictable
lies lionization and making a hero out
of the guy i i mean that that's if you
want my one-line analysis it's that i
did think it was interesting when he
says i support black lives matter
um you know a lot has been made of that
was a calculated lie he doesn't really
support them or he very narrowly said i
support their right to demonstrate and
that it was like now i don't know you
know okay he said he supports black
lives matter it might well be true it it
wasn't like the most interesting part of
it for me but for me it was like you
know the beginning of the very
predictable hero tour where then he met
with trump and they did the pictures
with the thumbs up and the whole thing
it's just part of the whole media tour
oh yeah for sure i i i've been seeing a
lot of mixed reactions online because i
know there were a ton of conservatives
who wanted written house to be this like
ride or die angel of mega conservatism
you know where he'd go up there and he'd
screech like let's go brandon and tucker
cross and do the okay sign and then like
you know uh
talk about trans bathrooms in 77
when i was watching the interview you
know he came off
most to me like a really like partisan
republican like talking points you'd
hear from uh from from like a you know a
pundit when talking about self-defense
and the trial specifically oh i agree
the moment specific sorry to interrupt
the moment where i knew this was like so
calculated and coached and it's okay to
be coached i'm not saying it's bad
being prepared for an interview okay uh
was where he started to say
it's the moment where he says the trial
wasn't about kyle rittenhouse it was
about self-defense and then he says if i
was guilty
no one would be able and then he goes no
no no
he he goes no one would be privileged
and it's like that's the language his
lawyer used that's the language his
lawyer used you know
that's i feel like that was absolutely
you know where the the
soviet spy um conditioning kicked in or
whatever you know where he was um most
trying to deliver a point because i felt
like in contrast the rest of the
interview he came off relatively
measured you know i'm not here singing
his praises or anything i'm not saying
he you know came off like a
hero of the revolution but oh god hold
on
there we go oh my god what was that that
sounded like a gerbil
no i it's
coffee i i have cinnamon on top
okay
um but but um not to sing his praises or
anything like that but um for the rest
of it it felt to me like he was sort of
passively rejecting a lot of the stuff
that i would expect him to cash in on
you know he said that the left and the
right had both exploited him for
political gain
um over the course of the trial you know
he seems to be
uninterested in these showboaty you know
marjorie taylor green beaubert you know
gazar attempts at getting him as some
kind of staffer and that's interesting
to me you know because i i feel like a
lot of people on the right were let down
you know they wanted him to be
the the emblem of of everything they've
been screeching about for the past 18
months
i totally agree with that and i thought
um again
whether it was calculated or not
uh i actually think that he
i don't know i mean there you know you i
don't know how much you looked at the
online sphere in reaction and there were
a lot of people furious about his blm
comment and a lot of people who didn't
think he was quote tough enough when
given the opportunity to send a message
to joe biden or whatever the case may be
but there was a lot of that stuff where
it seems like the the perspective is
um just kind of say something to appease
anyone who wants to be appeased because
the people who want to be mad will be
mad either way
yeah yeah for sure because my my the
advice that i've given at this point is
that
at least to my audience you know you
can't take any of this seriously anymore
um
if you take it seriously you know like
if you take it with with great gravitas
you know oh written house this that or
the other you know you come off like a
sore loser
now
rittenhouse himself acknowledged that if
he was black he might not have been
given the same prosecutorial privileges
that he was given being a white guy
which i thought was interesting but uh i
i feel like now that we're like on the
other side of the verdict it's
irresponsible because i've seen this
somewhere in online spaces you know to
go oh well he only got off because of
white supremacy or all right because of
this that or the other because you can't
really substantiate that stuff directly
even though it's sociologically
omnipresent and it makes you come off
like you know like a sore loser like uh
you know oh you only won because you
cheated you know um how do you feel
about that i actually i mean i have not
uh
i don't know that i mentioned white
supremacy during the trial other than
the controversy over the picture which
was not admitted as evidence um but have
people been saying after the fact that
the verdict is a result of white
supremacy i didn't even hear that
i just i not i don't think through
official sources more just like um
people getting angry on twitter a couple
of viral tweets stuff like that i think
because if a conservative sees that
right i mean it must be pretty
reaffirming you know like ridden house
wins and then the left engages in
behavior that to them reinforces the
idea that the left will call anything
racist if they don't like the outcome
um
same with the same with the stuff with
the you know the interview with tucker
carlson you know i think it's quite
funny this ideological dissonance i
think between the party and
rittenhouse's behavior post verdict um
but if you look into it too hard
i feel like you're opening yourself up
for a lot of disappointment i'm just i'm
just kind of hoping that something
you know really funny happens in the
future like he gets into a beef with
some conservative like prominent
conservative who says that he's not
living up to their expectations i think
that'd be very funny yeah or i mean
there's always the chance that like like
well do you remember the george
zimmerman trayvon martin case
when that was done it was pretty obvious
that this was not the end of zimmerman's
legal troubles and indeed it wasn't with
rittenhouse i actually do think
now he seems to be better advised he
actually may stay out of trouble
indefinitely whereas with zimmerman it
seemed like the guy was so out of
control that it was bound to get you
know and he had a domestic violence
issue and some other issue i actually
don't know that that's likely to happen
with written house
yeah i think i agree i i would be very
surprised if he ever does anything like
that again you know not not because i
think he's undergone this gigantic
ideological shift he just doesn't seem
to mean like the kind of person who's
predisposed towards
violence i guess i could say like like
it's it seems at least from his behavior
maybe that's
how he's shaped up since then that
whatever decision making led him to go
and do his vigilante bit over at kenosha
it was was more or less circumstantial
that he's not going to be like gunning
for the next opportunity i could be
wrong but i think that's true i don't
think he's going to get any easy shots
in like that no i think if in a few
months or in a couple years there's
another similar event and some other you
know antioch illinois or whatever some
equivalent place that's driving distance
from where he is
i i would be surprised if he chooses to
show up to guard a business with an
ar-15 quite frankly
yeah ridden house the written house
inning two i don't i don't think i'm
ready for that one i think i need a bit
of a break i it's i'm i'm interested in
seeing how things go i mean best case
scenario is that he stays out of stuff
and just lives a regular life from now
on which you know i think would be ideal
but
obviously the talking points for the
trial will remain you know i know you
don't do debates as often i guess as i
do but
when you see conservatives say you know
like the liberal media lied about this
that or the other what do you what do
you say to that like what talking points
do you have how do you plan to address
that what will probably be years of
accusations of of bias right now i have
no i mean i i've not talked to anyone
who has really
asked me to address that i mean my
audience knows i i basically don't watch
corporate media other than specific
things that
i plan to talk about on my show
and i also don't even really remember
the coverage from the beginning of it so
i mean if it becomes an omnipresent
thing to use your term i will have to
think about that uh but i just don't
even
i don't know i mean it's it's just not a
conversation i've even had up to this
time
okay that's fair
to go back to the white supremacy thing
though to go back a little bit because i
didn't want to get away from that too
immediately the issue i have with that
is
you can always say
that on some level that's the
explanation and it's essentially an
indefeasible argument um and i'm
reminded of there's this recent um
there's this like a local story that a
couple people i know were involved in
related to an art show and the idea was
like hey you know we're going to have an
art show but in order to prevent
possible bias
on the basis of the identity of the
artists everything will be blind judged
so nobody will know the identity of the
artists great
um and then there was without getting
into the exact details there was like a
reaction about
the
rankings for the pieces of art where
people started saying you know even
though it was blind
you had an a jury in the art show that
was all white and that's reflected in
their choices and then later it came out
actually most of the art jury were
minorities
so it wasn't actually that and then the
next argument became well
but they were privileged minorities and
one of them went to harvard and so their
perspective
is still emblematic so it's like
well
you you're never going to be satisfied
that it was anything other than that and
and it seems sort of like a similar
thing to what you're talking about
right right completely non-falsifiable i
think there are times where you can make
that argument fairly like for example
the ahmad arbury case the police not
charging until public pressure mounted
yes i am very comfortable saying that
you know
i can't say you know any one of the cops
are like clan members or nothing you
know nothing particularly direct but
that absolutely feels like something
which warrants a criticism uh along
those lines but you you could apply
anything anywhere anytime and you see
people applying it in instances where
it's entirely unwarranted uh if it's
non-falsifiable you have to have a
really good way of using it a really
good reason to use it otherwise you
could just sort of
throw it out there blindly like like for
instance i mean you know we've kind of
seen the opposite a little bit i think
conservatives are really interested in
getting kind of like
a comeuppance to the ahmad arbory
verdict that um wisconsin
is is it being called a terror attack
when they drove into that um
well i think the right is definitely
calling it that although i i mean it may
be the right term for it
yeah it might be i i don't know what
developments have been made on potential
motive i know the driver was a black guy
and i've been seeing people at least you
know people my comment section of
response they were like well what are
you going to talk about this black guy
that killed these white people so i
think that they're they're looking to
invoke kind of the opposite i remember
after george floyd was murdered there
was that five-year-old white kid who was
killed by that random black guy it
wasn't racially motivated yes
yeah yeah and they were like where is
the justice for this five-year-old white
kid what do you care about floyd but not
about this and it was just like
the guy was caught he's going to jail
forever nobody was defending him you
know right that was the difference that
was the difference at the time which is
it was just there there's no chance that
anybody's getting away with anything
here
yeah so there's nothing really to
prote i mean it's it's it's horrible of
course
i feel like so much of the discourse
these days concerning criminal justice
and race relations is really just
waiting for the next highly publicized
murder
and
and seeing how the discourse evolves
around it it feels like the discourse
never evolves unless it's being
catalyzed by some horrible random act of
violence now along those lines
um the things that
i have been more you know it's like
there's i don't know how much you're
aware but like for example
the community around stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii has taken issue with
my perspective on the written house
trial and
some others anecdotally have and i've
continued to say
for me it looks like the facts point to
totally plausible self-defense as an
argument and i expect not guilty for me
the bigger concern here is that this is
all part of the unique american gun
culture
where guns are seeing as a seen as a
sort of totally normal and sensible way
to to solve problems and that uh this
event in principle was not really
problematic with all the people carrying
the you know is it like the parenting
can you imagine what would have happened
if when i was 16 or 17
any of my parents had gotten hold that i
was thinking of even going to such an
event never mind going armed never mind
you know i'm going to go protect the
business like there's so many other
layers to this you know
yeah i um no no no i i completely agree
the issue and i think legal eagle put
out a great video that talks about this
is that self-defense is not even close
to being a good metric for responsible
social behavior where sometimes you have
situations where a group of people can
act somewhat irresponsibly and you have
an escalated searing of self-defense
killings until the last man standing is
the one that gets the not guilty verdict
uh the the you can't
the idea that something is self-defense
or like justified self-defense is not in
any way like a holistic moral
exoneration of their behavior especially
with i mean you get cases like this
sometimes there was one that i saw um
where i think it was a gas station
attendant was being robbed
at gunpoint and the gas station
attendant actually disarmed the the
robber and pointed the gun back at the
rubber and then a passing police officer
who saw through the window
one man pointing a gun at the other
shot
the the gas station uh guy you know if
you're in a movie theater one person
starts shooting the second person shoots
in self-defense now there are two people
shooting yeah it's it gets really tough
to judge these situations and that's why
i hate the whole vigilante mob violence
response you know just
marauding through the nighttime streets
as rioters and looters sort of gallivant
around like this is you're you're
maximizing the likelihood of violence
here it's not about protection it
doesn't protect anything agreed yeah and
i don't know if you remember that i mean
when you mentioned the movie theater i'm
guessing you're alluding to the aurora
batman movie theater incident right
yeah oh yeah and in that but i mean
broadly too like just imagine being in
that situation that you hear like
gunshots coming from either side of the
room like right right well i guess my
point was going to be at the time i
don't know if you remember there were
people saying the problem is that the
movie theaters are gun-free zones and
there weren't armed people there
and then you say well hold on a second
you're saying if there had been
additional shooters in the dark theater
it would have been better and then they
usually will retreat to well no if it's
known that it's not a gun-free zone the
shooter wouldn't have attempted this
there in the first place which seems to
completely ignore that a lot of these
public shooting incidents are not people
thinking clearly in that way anyway you
know
they're going there to die they a lot of
these people expect to be suicided by
cops they're not going to be deterred by
the knowledge that one in a hundred
people might have brought their glock to
a to a batman screening right i i i
really agree though about the the sort
of the sociological implications because
if if you want to take like a really
deep personalized stance i think that
written house ultimately is a victim of
a lot of um social
tendencies yeah here here in the states
gun culture being a huge part you know
the obsession with and this is like a
long-standing conservative thing you
know uh racial protests are leading to
violence in the streets our civilization
is being destabilized we need strong
people out there with guns this
narrative has been around since before
the civil rights movement but it always
ends in violence it's possible to
believe that too with not a drop of
racism in your body you know you can
believe that totally
race neutrally but it's a way of getting
sometimes non-racist people
in line with sort of the the systemic
uh
you know
white supremacist tendency you know you
know what i mean absolutely and i wonder
i mean
the the problem is that when you say
what's the full conclusion to this it's
everybody would be safest if just
everybody had a gun
and unfortunately like under the
paradigm we have
in which people can obtain firearms
and all of the specifics that only leads
to a lot of people
who currently don't have guns and have
violent impulses having the same
impulses plus the guns in more
situations and so they see the logical
conclusion as once everybody's armed no
one would ever shoot anybody because you
know everybody's armed and you'll end up
getting shot but it's like they already
know they're likely to end up getting
shot and it doesn't deter them now
yeah they they they clearly don't i i
was um
i was actually present at a shooting
once you know oh really uh
at santa monica college back in 20 i
don't know something 13 there was uh
there was a shooting there at the
library just outside of it well i was
further in and the guy uh you know came
there i think to be suicided by cop
that's that's always how the sense right
they very rarely get captured alive the
the whole an armed society is a polite
society thing is absolute [ __ ] it's
mathematically disprovable
don't get me wrong i'm a huge uh you
know proponent of gun rights i have six
guns uh just just off to my right right
now um
but there's a huge difference between
gun ownership and gun culture and the
gun culture thing the idea that guns are
like this you know
valuable
weapon of you know social righteousness
they're an extension of your masculinity
they'll solve any problem you will be
attacked every day of your life if
you're not armed that [ __ ] that
paranoid fear-mongering that's i think
the
critical issue you know the swiss have
plenty of guns in their households but
they're all you know
ex-military training you know kept clean
stored up in the attic type deals no
it's just it's quite simple if you ask
the swiss
do you see
guns
as maybe being the way to solve a social
political or interpersonal problem
the answer would be
almost 100 percent no
whereas if you poll people in the u.s
and there was recently a poll done here
more general it didn't say guns but it
said violence but i'm sure if you
repeated the poll with guns
a lot more people in the u.s believe
that at least on some of those
interpersonal political or social guns
are a valid way to solve that problem so
you take that perspective among some
people and you combine it with a ton of
guns it's not shocking what the
outcome's going to be
yeah or or people who think that having
a gun in your house will make you safer
it won't mathematically you're not going
to stop a burglar or a robber or
whatever that's not going to happen or
people who think open carry makes like
community safer or people think
concealed carry is like like you'll be
mugged like every other week you know
it's it's nonsense but people believe
this down in their in their gut i mean
down to their core i i'll just say by
the way because otherwise my my commie
friends you know they'll get mad at me
the big thing that i that i advocate for
with regards to guns is i know that
we've got a ton of guns in this country
and i know a ton of them are held
by people with whom i share tremendous
political disagreements and if if things
get bad in this country you know really
destabilized
20 50 years i don't know whatever in the
future i would think it nice
if
relatively progressive city communities
were armed and not just the right-wing
militias that would start patrolling the
streets the moment they got the chance
you know yeah yeah i so i've my audience
knows like i've said before i don't
really talk about my
gun ownership or lack thereof or i just
don't see any real advantage to making
it a personal thing but i've said that
over the last few years
many of my progressive friends have
started
legally arming themselves and the reason
they cite is
i don't want the right wingers having
all the guns or being the only ones with
guns that's the number one reason they
cite many of them don't particularly
like shooting guns they're not target
practice people
they don't believe that in terms of
armed robberies or whatever they're
going to be statistically safer because
they but they say if we play this out
and the right is the only political side
that's armed that seems bad and that's
the number one reason they are pursuing
firearm ownership
totally agree i think that's a really
honorable reason you know if you if you
don't want it in the house because you
feel like you got like a mental health
risk or anything like that like you
could keep with a friend it's just that
i think the broader deterrent is
valuable is will will some lunatic with
an ar-15 refrain from shooting up a
denny's because six of the people in
there might be concealed carrying
probably not right but if an entire city
is
generally known to be full of gun owners
you know somewhere in their house will
that maybe deter potential destabilizing
militia action maybe it could i don't
know possibly it we have to have
something right i don't know yeah i
guess i don't know but i agree with you
that at the individual crime level at
least right now it doesn't seem to be a
factor that's taken into consideration
when people decide about committing
particular uh particular crimes now that
being said
um i do think it's
relevant i guess to mention that i don't
think that there's much advantage to
democrats at essentially any level
of talking about guns and gun safety
because it seems to only hurt them in in
any election that i've seen i'm curious
what you think about that not i'm not a
democrat i don't know to what extent you
even care about democrats winning
particular elections but it seems to me
that democrats talking about
guns
makes it a voting issue for the right to
come out and say we've got to protect
our gun rights by voting against this
person
yes i really wish they would shut up
please god beta or work is the last
thing we need there are so many
independents libertarians and even
moderate republicans who are generally
decent people who are terrified of the
government taking their guns there is no
reason to keep biting this bullet you
don't even have to go big pro gun just
shut up about it i just don't think
democrats yeah democrats aren't going to
not vote for biden if biden doesn't
really talk about the guns you know just
just lay off you know some simple oh i
support our second member rights then
shut up about it uh it's it's insane to
me it's it's borderline like they want
to lose there are so many people that
are
practically second amendment hardliners
i just don't know why anyone would
would
waste political capital on this and it
never even comes to anything what gun
regulations have we had meaningfully in
this country the last big one was the
bump stock ban but like really there are
hundreds of millions of guns we're never
going to ban all of those what points
there are even trying i agree i agree
and um i even mentioned this in the
context of beto running and the clip
from the democratic debate in 20
20 20 right he just ran i mean it feels
like so long ago i guess it was 2020
where he was asked wait so are you
saying you you would like take people's
ar15s and ak-47s and he like pauses and
says yes and it's like that's not going
to help him in running for governor in
texas at all
no in texas of all places i i don't know
i mean i guess it's a branding thing i
just i don't i'm just i'm not that
afraid of guns you know because the
attitudes that make people dangerous
when they hold guns are dangerous when
they're not holding them either way you
know the the the but they're able to do
more damage if they are holding guns oh
oh absolutely don't get me wrong guns do
not help but with hundreds of millions
of guns in the country i'm not like
holding my breath for a total removal um
you know maybe if we were japan and we
had like no guns in the country this
would be a different talking point but i
like you know if you have your average
like q and on nut they're probably going
to hurt me not through some sporadic
shooting in a theater they're probably
going to hurt me by voting for
politicians that are going to i don't
know criminalize being gay or whatever
do the people even vote i mean that's a
different question but
they have to with with marjorie taylor
green types in in the republican party i
feel like they've got to be at least
somewhat invigorated yeah that's
probably probably true i guess we'll see
in 2022 i mean the thing is a lot of
them are in safe red districts anyway so
even without like the queue contingent
they'll still win
that's true yeah though though you know
they'll in in the primaries you know
they'll vote in the crazier reds i think
um
it's it's really a shame how the
hardliner republicans are evangelical
boomers who will like vote they they
like put you know on their calendar
they'll mark off the voting day but the
hard-line lefties in this country are
all like bordega you know kropotkin
readers who believe in anti-electoralism
and won't even get out of bed for like
voting out trump it's pretty it's pretty
annoying
yeah i uh i don't know do you have a
sense of whether like
okay so in 2022 a bunch of them will get
reelected just because they're in safe
districts and there's a few additional q
people that are running in 22 but like
if trump doesn't run in 24 do you think
that this like cute trump movement just
goes away or do they become integrated
into the republican party the way the
tea party did
i think
i think it becomes fully integrated i
mean even if trump did something
spectacularly bad they've made you know
jfk jr like a legacy movement member in
spite of him never having anything to do
with anything right
um
it could because like the the attitude
doesn't go away republicans the
politicians i mean i feel like they're
terrified of their voters there was
recently those um that whistleblower
from facebook who said that at least in
europe i mean the the info was from
europe but i think this is universally
applicable there were far right
political parties who moved further to
the right to match the increasingly
radical views
of their constituencies so i i feel like
the snowball's rolling down the hill at
that point you know you you can take
desantis to take up the the
torch if you want but unfortunately i
think we're going to need some kind of
reconstruction tier social realignment
to really fix this
yes speaking of which i mean for people
in my audience who may not know you are
an actual bonafide socialist not you
know someone wrongly called a socialist
how is the fight for socialism going in
your mind
why would you ask me that you know you
know what i'm going why would you do
that
uh
look the the
the primary
goal of any socialist first and foremost
should be anti-fascism uh lenin allied
with uh social democrat groups to fight
against the fascists the thousand knives
in russia uh mao stopped fighting with
the um you know with with the um the
conservatives to fight off japan uh back
in the uh you know back in the 1930s
and they weren't even good socialists
like me i i just i think that
the the goal the black hundreds not the
thousands thank you the the the goal
first and foremost is i think right now
dealing with the republican party and i
think you can do that in ways which are
more or less advantageous for you know i
guess my long-term ideological goals um
but to be honest
we're not really in a position to build
anything right now outside of maybe the
little spattering of a labor movement
we've
we've got presently i guess we can
kindle that little fire like that little
you know match light to keep the wind
from blowing it out apart from that
though just keeping this country from
spiraling into nothing would be a good
uh
good
that's interesting to me because my my
perception of you is you're not really
like a tanky socialist in a very
particular sense and corrupt i mean
correct me if i'm wrong but um i was
talking to uh my dad the other day and i
don't know if you know but like i'm from
argentina my parents grew up in
argentina in the 60s 70s where there was
like the equivalent to the current tanki
movement they loved fidel castro and so
on and so forth and um
one of the things i was talking to my
dad about was this contingent in the
left now
that sometimes sort of almost sounds
right wing like without naming anybody
in particular like they often like
authoritarians like putin and castro and
others they you know whatever you know
the full kind of like package of the
thing and what my dad said was for him
this is such an old playbook it's the
exact same thing that he was seeing
among
the argentinian tanki left in the late
60s and early 70s that it's it's not a
new thing it's that there's always been
this contingent of the so-called left
and he was close to that like in in
argentina he was part of like a
jew what was called a jewish socialist
movement
and um it was very different than the
people who like the russian and all the
different stuff
what's your pers are you part of that
group or what's your perception of that
group it seems to me that you're not
part of that group
well um
with i i i feel like um
uh i'm trying i'm trying to think of the
most measured way of of putting this i
i feel like a lot of people are looking
for a kind of social rebirth uh that
people when they're desperate or when
they don't have much going for them
they're looking for some kind of direct
meaningful movement that they think will
radically change everything they don't
like about the world okay and those
people are usually um
tankies or fascists uh where where i'm
not this isn't an argument against
revolutionary action but rather it's
this they they need this um they have an
emotional attachment to this you know um
epigenesis this massive social revival
but then there are people who approach
their political project
um in in i guess what i'd consider to be
a more decentralized way where it's not
really about the direct attachment to
that process or its outcomes but about
the
the the principles that you you try to
meet on your way there historically in
every major socialist revolution you've
seen these two groups fight and one of
them win and it's almost always the
authoritarians after lenin won the
worker councils which he relied on for
the first 18 or so months of the soviet
union were quickly disbanded their
members killed or sent to siberia uh you
know uh in mao's china you had a similar
situation the students were weaponized
against the um the teachers and all the
old guard were killed off and then
eventually the students were sent off to
the farms it's this this happens time
and time again it's it's deeply
unfortunate and i think the ultimate
issue is that it's just way easier to be
authoritarian it's so much easier it's
way easier you get a military together
you entrust everything to a glorious
leader and you trust them to
enact these principles but this just
doesn't work it's the reason why
sometimes they come off a little bit
less i guess revolutionary than other
people who believe in such a thing i
think you need to lay the right
groundwork you have to make sure the
material conditions are ripe the working
class needs to be the agent of its own
emancipation with revolutionaries only
being a tool to be used by the working
class if you do the opposite where the
working class is a tool to be used by
the revolutionaries you get a repeat of
you know 100 years of failed socialism
they're just uh you know an angry mob to
be weaponized until you can appoint a
new elite cast of political agents yeah
i mean in our last conversation and i'm
getting the sense now you believe in a
more uh i guess what we would call a
gradual transition to the
system you believe is the ideal system
yeah rather than a revolutionary
transition
my guess is we're not really going to
have a choice this is my guess i don't
know this of course but i think climate
change is going to get bad enough uh
that we're going to deal with economic
downturn resource um you know
shortages uh and climate refugees and
that this is going to lead to enough
destabilization that america and a bunch
of other countries are going to have
like internal crises over what to do and
at that point it's either going to be
like some kind of
you know fascist government or something
more radical more left-leaning i think
at that point we're not gonna have a
choice like things are gonna really bad
there so for me it's just about laying
the bricks until you reach that point
you're not like a cia or anything right
i not to my knowledge uh as as many
times i've been accused of settling
um okay couple other things i i wanted
to ask you um hold on now i oh do you
know so
who is mr beast and what did he do in
the last 48 hours that people are going
crazy about
he's a big youtuber um a very big one uh
uh kind of philanthropic he reinvests a
lot of his money into the projects that
he does uh you know like we're all
stranded on an island person to find
this treasure gets a billion dollars or
whatever he's made a recreation of squid
game have you seen squid game i'm i'm
aware of it
you should see it it's good he's
recreating it he built all the sets you
know oh it was mean like in real life
yeah yeah it got 400 or so people i
don't think they're uh spoilers i don't
think they're killing the people brought
on board okay uh the way they did in the
um in the show proper but um i could be
wrong i actually haven't seen it okay
all right i'm gonna it's so it's so it's
actually something worth being aware of
oh oh yeah oh squid game was lovely i
really really enjoyed it i just mean
this whole mr beast like version of it
probably i've seen screenshots and i've
seen little video clips and i'm probably
going to watch it either today or
tomorrow because it does look pretty
funny it's actually going to be the
first mr beast video i've ever seen so
okay fair uh new to me now here's the
other thing as a socialist i wanted to
ask you your thoughts on a debate i was
having with my audience earlier and i
think you're going to be uniquely
positioned to weigh in on this
do you believe absolutely that tesla's
inexperience with building vehicles
is going to slowly allow legacy
companies like audi porsche and mercedes
to chip away at tesla's electric vehicle
market share by virtue of simply being
better at building nice cars
unironically yes absolutely i recently
watched a video which linked to a few
articles talking about how tesla's cars
are not particularly well designed or
well priced tesla is unique mostly in
making them cool um i don't think that
elon musk is a competent businessman uh
outside of the marketing element i think
that in terms of actually like a
sustainable long-term functioning
product he over-prioritizes glitz and
glam and under-prioritizes like
long-term
sensible investment um and
and i i think very little of the man but
no really like electric cars have been
around for what nearly a century um and
there are cheaper and better electric
cars in the market they're just not
teslas i think that once the hype wears
off and it will eventually
it you know nothing like this stays
around forever i think other companies
are going to search back and they're
going to be able to sort of scavenge the
clout that that tesla's carved out i
tend to agree i'm going to be i am both
an owner of stock and of a vehicle
and i am going to slowly uh start
disassociating from the stock slowly bit
by bit um and i'm looking very strong i
mean here's the here's the thing here's
what makes it very inconvenient to have
any non-tesla electric vehicle right now
the range of teslas is still
the best
and
the fast charging network makes it
really difficult to do long trips with
any other vehicle
yeah it's the it's the infrastructure
you lay down if you're the first one to
really capture or corner the market you
can edge other people out and force them
you know to yeah so hopefully um
i don't know hopefully we could um
oh man can you imagine if there was
legislation on that so that like all the
tesla charging stations were retrofitted
so that they're universally usable yeah
i mean
the problem is then a lot of them have
eight a lot of them only have eight to
twelve stalls
then
it's there's not an if if they were open
i'm not saying don't do it i think that
that would allow me to much more easily
look at other types of electric vehicles
because i know i could use the fast
charger but
those fast chargers would be permanently
full if they were open to every electric
vehicle just the reality
yeah i think um i mean i'm a big
advocate for public transport it's not
really relevant to this convo because
you and i are probably not going to be
taking buses everywhere but i i guess
that'd be kind of nice long term i i
feel like um
the the dream
would be um
would be that you could have this kind
of thing at your house wouldn't it i
mean every house has an electric
you know current running to it if if
there was some way to like commercially
be like here for 150 bucks here's a a
you know an install you can get uh
there's a cord that like plugs out
through the garage you just pull it out
and there you go you're charging
i mean that basically exists it's a
little more than than
i mean listen you know i don't know how
much we want to get into this but with
if you just have a regular plug without
having any electrical work done you get
a cable with your car and you can charge
it the thing is it'll only charge like
four to five miles per hour which is
very slow
you can then put in like a dryer plug a
240 volt that'll get you like 35 40
miles per hour
and that's what i have but you got to
pay an electrician to put that in unless
you're going to run it all the way up to
wherever your dryer is you know but but
i think the the bigger issue is when
traveling away from home
yeah yeah that tracks i think um i mean
the goal would be
that uh we would um
we would only use these cars in
you know short distance travel i think
right at least when i think of like a
good sustainable electric infrastructure
future you know you have your car for
like picking up groceries in the city
but if you want to travel like far far
you know you've got uh robust train or
subway networks and you get there there
are local options i think that'd be
quite nice yeah yeah i mean in practical
terms we just don't have that you know
if you want to go if you're in new york
city and you want to go to as i recently
did a wedding in maine
um
maybe you could take a train but it
might take 30 hours because you've got
to go to maybe montreal first i don't
even know how you would do it uh
obviously that's lacking right now
yeah oh we can always dream of the
future sure there are a few channels i'm
really really fond of um adam's
something does a couple of videos making
fun of um
tesla and elon musk in in in reasonable
ways i mean you know critiquing the
technology and uh not just the bikes
talks about sustainable infrastructure
and i love both of them very much
european cities are so wonderfully
designed compared to our own so livable
um it's one of the reasons i like
seattle there are portions of seattle
where everyone's always walking not
because there's no parking but more so
because there's such a robust mix of
residential and commercial zoning that
there's always something interesting to
do in the area
speaking of seattle by the way i don't
know how devastating this was to you i'm
guessing that up until recently
you were likely the biggest
seattle-based youtuber but with the
arrival of jay kenji lopez alt in
seattle who has i believe one of the
best youtube channels in the cooking
space
i think that that may have knocked you
down a peg i don't know if you're aware
of that
no no it's it's good for me um if if i
can never sort of um you know find my
way on set during a recording or you
know throw a rock through the window try
to like get my name on it you know i i
it opens up opportunities for um cloud
sharking on my part that i'm really
looking forward to wait am i even wrong
on that is kenji in portland oregon now
i don't remember i know he's up in the
pacific northwest somewhere what i said
may have been completely wrong now i'm
not even oh i don't even know who you're
referring to
gotcha
i'm just i'm just working with it the
the only the only cooking youtubers that
i've enjoyed are binging with babish and
the um
um the uh that one big corporate one
that everyone stopped watching because
there were accusations of racism from
the manager god what was that called oh
i don't know that one i don't know
um
bon appetit oh and then they all often
make their own youtube channels no my
favorite song i am kenji and jacques
pepe
jacques pepe yeah that is a frenchman i
sir it is indeed yeah
okay actually he's cuban would you
believe that
well
if it came from you yeah if it came from
a less reputable source though you gotta
you gotta watch yourself you know i
believe anything you say no he is french
i believe he's from lyon or something
like that uh oh and also toon tune for
thai cooking you can't beat toontoon
geez are you getting me cultured over
here you know i'm really more of a
chicken nuggies guy myself so we're
we're branching out of my comfort zone a
little bit do you not cook for your
tenants either i'm sorry roommates
okay okay i i work and i pay the rent
okay these these these [ __ ] can cook
from time to time no we we we really we
really don't make that much we get those
um what do you call them hello fresh
yeah uh
with like like 12 meals a week split
between the three of us you know um and
those are really good by the way i was
taken away because you know they deliver
it and then it's like in a box for a bit
i thought it'd be like so-so some of the
meals that i've had there are
legitimately
the
uh
some of the best food i've ever had i
can't promote them though though because
apparently they did some union busting
recently oh wow i didn't hear about that
everyone ignore what i yeah are you for
or against spatchcocking when you do a
chicken on the grill
spatchcocking um you're gonna you're
gonna have to help me give me give me a
brief description it's basically you
butterfly the chicken to make it the
same thickness throughout in order to
have even cooking
uh yes yes you have to cut you have to
cut it down also the the best
the best cut of chicken okay
is about a half an inch okay you you you
you cut it in half you smash the chicken
a half an inch deep that's the perfect
chicken cut right there a half inch deep
like yeah like the thickness is about a
half an inch uh once you've flattened or
butterflied the chicken breast right oh
you're talking about chicken breast
oh are you talking about thighs i'm
talking about the entire chicken
oh
i see no i've never hammered an entire
chicken down into a pasty no no you
don't need a hammer you don't need a
hammer at all listen i'm going to leave
you to the to investigating
spatchcocking and i'm sure you'll have a
strong position on it by the next time
we talk
oh i'm sure i'll i'll learn i'll give it
a shot you know i'll i'll share my
success or failure story with you but
your idea of just smashing a full
chicken into a paste is an interesting
one i've never considered it but i might
it's it's how owls eat things okay just
sort of grind it up into a into a you
know a little uh pellet it's it's been a
pleasure speaking with you thank you for
taking the time ian vosh uh a gentleman
and a scholar great to speak to you as
always
david mann peck pacman you take care
enjoy the stream and uh i'll talk to you
eventually all right very good take care
there it is folks uh world renowned
streamer ian vosh very good take care
there
there you go
that was quite quite nice i think i feel
like we uh we had a pleasant
conversation there you cut him off no no
he cut out he was speaking to no i
didn't cut him off he quit mid-sentence
oh my gosh talking to his audience there
i didn't mean to um
excuse me
all right very good
excellent guys what a stream it's been
an incredible day i want to say thanks
to sam the sleazebag elsh narfin and
stace face for the twitch prime subs
welcome to all of our new viewers
we're going to be back at it on
monday
all right guys monday thanks for joining
me on the rare
black friday stream
and we'll see everybody very soon